les SAV de la Fournaise c'est une
société qui existe depuis 2 ans et demi
environ et on fait de la fabrication de
transformation de produits issu de
l'Agriculture de la
Réunion la méthodologie de travail elle
est simple on achète nos matières
premières avec des agriculteurs ou des
intermédiaires qui sont très proches des
agriculteurs on travaille le produit
après dans notre selon nos recettes et
ensuite ils sont distribués chez nos
clients alors les points forts de la
société actuellement c'est la
diversification des produits et
l'originalité des produits tout produit
transformés chez nous on rajoute une
touche d'originalité avec des saveurs
locaux donc tout ce qui est vanille
convava gingembre R de Savana qui font
l'authenticité de nos
produits
actuellement on est en phase de
recrutement donc avec le le Pôle Emploi
on a mis en place un des plans de
formation préalable au recrutement et
donc actuellement on est sur quatre
stagi on travaille avec les produits
d'ici de la Réunion quoi monte un petit
peu
aussi ce qu'on fait c'est quand même
produit de qualité j'espère que ça
marchera ça marche déjà bien donc je
pense que ça
peut que mieux marcher
hein je suis issu de d'une formation
agricole donc brevet technicien agricole
j'ai pas le diplôme j'ai eu envie de
monter les saveurs de la fnaise par
rapport à une expérience que j'ai eu
avec avec ma maman elle faisait de la
transformation avant en moi donc quand
elle a arrêté j'ai décidé de reprendre B
de créer cette activité et aussi par
rapport à à l'envie de sauvegarder les
produits de la Réunion les produits
terroir le sport le sport est pour moi
primordial dans les moment où j'étais
vraiment au plus bas des prettes j'ai
tout donné dans le sport courir tous les
jours marcher courir et ça m'a reboosté
ça m'a remis sur sur de bons
rail
au quotidien c'est quelqu'un qui est
assez calme passionné
attentionné et qui va vers l'avant de
s'investir dans la société avec lui
c'est c'est au quotidien
etut faut être à ses côtés que ça soit à
la maison mais aussi dans
l'entreprise le challenge créateur pour
moi c'est c'est un trin c'est c'est une
éap contournable de ma de mon parcours à
moi
professionnel c'est juste être finaliste
c'est juste pour moi la récompense d'un
de mon parcours qui a pas été évident
c'est c'est aussi un remerciement à tous
les gens qui ont cru en moi participez
au prix du public votez pour votre
candidat favori jusqu'au 27 novembre sur
www.cg974.fr et la page facebook
challenge des
créateurs just like the time before and
time before
that